foreign
[Music]
Ty for instance is a real Con in itself
because people use vulnerability to
manipulate others my brother's in
trouble he has the money how much do
they want 350 000 well the film sort of
acknowledges this great truth that all
of us in some aspect of our lives are
not quite what we've seen we can't get
through life without being a little
deceitful enjoy the show
yeah you're a student getting my PhD
first impressions are only the tip of
the iceberg it's important to really
take the time to get to know somebody
before you start revealing things about
yourself or inviting them into your home
let's face it we're practically
strangers
money can turn people into their
animalistic self because it is so
necessary to survive
my friend you can't cheat on us man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark these are really smart people all
of them and they require you to be
really smart to follow all their
strategies it's people pretending to be
people that they're not you really
should not judge a book by its cover
behind it there's all these other layers
and things and intentions and I think
maybe it's about asking ourselves to be
a little bit more Vigilant with what we
are susceptible to
you're ready for a test run
[Music]